Tick Tock Legend now YouTube Legend now
oh Professor hey let's go man glad to be
here bro yeah it's crazy because I
remember watching you back in the day
man like uh you know when I was a kid I
loved and one's mixtapes I remember uh
you know obviously rest in peace to uh
Escalade uh big bro Skip to My Lou who
ended up in the league great for Alston
uh hot sauce yeah there was all these
guys that were like celebrities all the
big Bros yeah yeah and then like the and
one [__] influenced so much [__] in
culture because like without and one
there's no NBA Street you know what I
mean they're baggy shorts yeah the baggy
shorts just like there was just so much
that like you know I feel like uh and
then anyone ended up in Walmart you know
what I'm saying which kind of made it
uncool but you know yeah one yeah you
know new ownership I think it changed
hands
five times or something since I was
there yeah so it's in the hands of
ownership now that you know has it in
Walmart I guess they probably hey
they're winning a lot of fun they're
good they're making a ton of money
you've seen what Shaq did right so I
think it's Shaq and and one is like the
two head sports brands of Walmart so I'm
sure they kill it from a financial
standpoint I was gonna say you were 18
when you started doing uh the N1 stuff
right yeah you know three oh three so
how did you initially because obviously
you're very good at basketball
so at what point in time did you say
well I don't know if I could make it to
the league but this is something this is
like an ulterior or not an ulterior but
alternative uh route I can go to be a
professional Hooper uh so so initially I
came out there I was really like a fan
it just kind of happened on accident but
I always trying to make the NBA right
right but I was actually a benchwarmer
at a community college so it wasn't it
wasn't gonna happen it wasn't looking
great for me at that moment but after my
freshman year in college I improved by
like 300 like it's crazy I finally hit
the weights I'm playing every day with
guys who are going D2 and D1
I already spent all my time hooping but
now I'm doing three a days right you
know I mean like literally make 500
jumpers before class go to class
230s open gym yeah hit the weights come
work on your game again in the evening
either at a difference non-stop or right
there so non-stop so I dedicated even
more time
to the grind and improved I didn't
realize how fast you could improve by
the end of that spring after my freshman
year I was like the best player in the
gym
you know I mean with my with my
teammates and stuff like that but then
and one came
and the year before I went to animal the
first the first uh Nationwide tour they
had it's already popping yeah they had
season one on ESPN already I'm a fan I'm
actually wearing anyone head to toe
before I'm even on there like culturing
it trying the moves everywhere I go yeah
so
uh I go up there as a fan just to watch
but I knew they had an open run because
I had played the year before and I got
to play one game against the players I
think I was going against like sick with
it at the time wow a headache those guys
were up there so
hopped in the open run got some moves
off some people were going crazy got
voted in to play against team and one in
mind you I'm not even thinking the route
of Streetball I actually don't even
think I belong there to be honest
because it was such like a a hood in the
city right you know what I'm saying like
you're just like scrawny little white 18
year old kid yeah I was just talking to
half man half man half amazing the other
day and he was telling me you know we
were talking about the street ball
versus the NBA debate but remember he
was in the limo he's like yo we need to
see that commercial remember the hood
All-Stars versus the NBA All-Stars I had
a pair of those Vince Carter's I think
they were called the half man half
amazings the Vince Carters were like the
and ones that were like one one half
color one way the Tai Chi yeah those are
hard they gave they gave Vince Carter
that name from him though from Anthony I
didn't know that word half man half
amazing yeah I think Kenny Smith took
bit he knew half man amazing
streetballer but gave it to wow yeah I
remember he was a little upset about
that but right anyway we were talking
about that that uh the debate but you
know I didn't think I was a hood off I
didn't think I could be in the mix with
the hood all-stars so like I'm doing it
from a fan standpoint
you know I played next thing I know I'm
going back and forth with hot sauce in
the in the main and one game and then
they asked me to go on tour so mine kind
of happened on accident but I did try to
pursue the NBA up until 2007 playing the
CBA which was like the G League yeah and
then uh the original G League the
original g-league that's how high I got
but then like man the politics of the
game though I lost some good when I got
in the game when I they I think they got
me there for ticket sales yeah because
you were a name bro like you you ended
up kind of being like the like kind of
the face and one for a minute you know
yeah so I got there I think it was like
a ticket sale thing but then like I got
a little time when especially when the
starting point guard it was actually
Stephon marbury's brother he got injured
for like three games so I started for
three games one of them I had over 20
points and like seven assists yeah the
other two I had like 15 and five or
something like that we lost one and one
two but when that dude got healthy man
they put him right back in the lineup
even though we weren't winning a game
before that right so it was like the
politics of the game you know people
looked at Street Bowl actually in that
time it was like it actually wasn't real
basketball so it didn't fit do you think
it like worked against you because
people perceived you as a street baller
and not our actual like you know
professional yeah yeah when it came to
the conventional game right it was a bad
thing Skip to My Lou even you know who
played in the NBA for over 10 years it
took him a while to get in though but he
had to let go of his Streetball
reputation I remember my year getting on
the tour 2003 was the last time he even
played any games he just stopped playing
on the tour he had a solid uh career too
and he had some good years with Orlando
and Houston like yeah he was good but
it's cool because it's actually funny
how it works because back then it was a
bad thing to the NBA high-ups now
the All-Star the Hall of Famers of today
grew up watching and one so like when I
meet you know like Paul George or Kyrie
they're like oh yeah you're my I'm gonna
watch you back inspired by you yeah love
it it's incredible I grew up off you
that shit's so crazy it's it's wild too
because like think about like NBA Street
they took so many of your guys's moves
and put them into that game yeah did
they ever like tap in with y'all like or
like because it they really took y'all's
moves and like literally it was just I
mean a legendary video game but I can
only imagine it's almost like with the
fortnite dances some of these dancers
you can turn on fortnite the dances are
in the game and then getting credit like
did y'all get any credit for any of the
NBA Street [__] uh people would mix it
up you know like they'd ask us they
think it's our game so we had two games
too so we I remember Street Hoops they
weren't great yeah I think what happened
was I remember the games yeah I think
was Street Hoops they probably saw that
and we're like oh we could do this
better yeah put the NBA stamp on it's
probably gold yep but then we came we
did and one street ball I actually
thought that was with Activision that
was a more I don't know if I play that
one yeah so that was a souped up version
but uh it was right around the buyout
from Amazon they got the marketing boost
and I don't think they were gonna do a
part two but it got bought out yeah so
uh I think honestly they just saw the
wave of it in the NBA smart for them to
capitalize on the street side of things